compliments du ministre de la défense
andré giraud à la société marcel
dassault compliment pour le succès du
premier vol du rafale effectué hier à
istres dans les bouches du rhône le
rafale est le prototype expérimental des
prochains avions de combat français
commentaires laurent boussier ira istres
en fin d'après-midi pour le rafale
c'était l'heure de vérité un premier vol
c'est toujours une aventure et même si
les ingénieurs les techniciens ont
toutes étudiées et tout calculer il
reste quand même une parcelle d'imprévus
qui rend l'instant du premier décollage
particulièrement important
hier pas de problème le vol a duré une
heure une heure pendant laquelle l'avion
atteint 1300 km heure et voler à plus de
onze mille mètres d'altitude
le prototype monoplace vie réacteurs de
neuf tonnes et demi dont la structure et
les composants en fonte l'avion de
combat le plus moderne du monde va
maintenant servir de banc d'essai à un
autre avion le rafale b presque
identique mais plus léger qui devrait
équiper l'armée de l'air et la marine
françaises à partir de 1995 enfin hier
le rafale a surtout pris une longueur
d'avancé sur son concurrent anglais qui
lui n'a toujours pas volé et ça c'est
important
au moment où des négociations sont en
cours avec la norvège les pays bas la
belgique et le danemark pour
d'éventuelles coopérations
le premier vol s'étant bien passé tous
les espoirs sont permis